the problem with language education
there's about 1.2 billion people in the
world learning a foreign language it's
one of the most common things that
people learn in the world everywhere in
the world except maybe for the u.s. it's
not that common in the US but everywhere
else so about 1.2 billion people
learning a foreign language now if you
look at it more deeply it turns out
about 800 million of them satisfy three
properties the first one is they're
learning English the second one is that
they are doing so in order to get a
better job or a job at all and the third
one is that they are of low
socio-economic condition so basically
most people learning a foreign language
are poor people learning English to make
more money or to make some money now the
the kind of ironic thing is that usually
the ways there are to learn languages in
particular to learn English cost a lot
of money so for example in the US
there's rosetta stone which is five
hundred to a thousand dollars in Latin
America there's a program called open
English which is about a thousand
dollars
so it's this ironic thing that most of
the people that need to learn a language
are poor people that are doing it so
that they can get money but it requires
quite a bit of money to do so which is
why with duolingo we decided to make a
completely free way to learn a language
and that's that's the whole premise of
duolingo when we started we thought we
have to make a way to learn a language
but it has to be 100% free when when we
started to a lingual was not just me it
was me and my co-founder whose name is
Severin hacker who is very funny because
his last name is hacker when we started
we we knew we wanted to do a free way to
learn languages this is what we wanted
to do but I mean it's easy to say that
it's free the problem is when something
is free you got to find a way to finance
it and to make it sustainable so the
question really became is how do we
teach languages for free but such that
we can actually finance the whole thing
the the solution to this came from many
of my previous projects have had this a
very similar idea and it's an idea that
can be traced back to an idea that I had
when I was a kid it was a terrible idea
but at the time I thought it was an
amazing idea and it was that I wanted to
have a gym where it was free to go to
the gym it was a free gym but all the
exercise equipment was connected to the
power grid and people when they went
there they would as they exercise they
would generate electricity that the gym
would sell to the power grid so that's
why it was free we wouldn't charge
people but we would make money by by
selling electricity to the to the
electric company turns out this is a bad
idea because it turns out humans are
actually not very good at making
electricity but I thought it was a good
idea at the time also there's another
reason why it's a bad idea it turns out
with Jim Economics actually most of the
money is made from people not showing up
whereas in this case we really needed
people to show up because we needed to
generate the electricity but it's not a
good idea but it's a very similar idea
what we ended up doing with with
duolingo and what I have used in my
previous projects where the idea is can
we offer a service for free but as we're
offering it for free can we extract some
value out of people doing the thing
anyways so in the case of the Jim it was
extracting electricity the question is
what value can we extract that of people
learning a language and and it turns out
what you can do is you can get people
who are learning a language to help with
translation language translation so what
we do with duolingo the way the way we
finance duolingo is that whenever
whenever we teach somebody a lesson so
we may teach them about food words in a
given language at the end once we've
taught them about it we say hey if you
want to practice what you just learned
with something from the real world here
is this document that has never been
translated before that is in the
language that you're learning can you
help us translate it to your native
language and then we sell that
translation so for example a CNN is one
of our clients where the idea is that
CNN writes everything in English they
send it to us then people who are
learning English on duolingo in order to
practice their English they get a CNN
story in English and they have to
translate it into their native language
and now we get multiple people to
translate the same story and they vote
on each other's translations and at the
end we come up with one best translation
for the whole article and then we send
it back to CNN and CNN pays us for
having translated their article so
that's the idea is that people are as
they're learning a language they're
they're helping us through the
translation and then this is as they're
practicing it's completely optional you
can learn everything there is to learn
on dueling
without ever practicing this way but
about half the people who get presented
an opportunity to translate say they
would like to translate it so it ends up
working out ever since we launched
duolingo it has been it has grown a lot
we know 42 million users from 0 to 42
million users in two years we are the
most popular way to learn languages in
the world they are in fact in in the
United States there are more people
learning a language on duolingo than in
the entire US public school system so
there's we have a lot of people learning
our language they're also not paint and
and also in in the developing world
there are a lot of people there are
millions of people who before we're just
not able to learn a language they didn't
have access to it whereas now we do a
lingual they do so we've already changed
the industry I mean if you look at for
example the stock price of rosetta stone
it's really it's really not good but I
think we're only getting started I think
I think we're nowhere near as good as I
want to be I I think we should be able
to teach you a language I don't know
three four times more effectively than
we do in terms of time it takes to learn
it and so that's we're gonna be working
on that and really making it so that we
are your your one-on-one tutor but it's
a computer one-on-one tutor and I think
we'll be able to do it
you